[Music]
it's an incredible discovery an ancient
abandoned alien space station filled
with precursor technology but now every
species in the galaxy is in a mad dash
to get there first and claim it for
themselves and right away you've got a
problem
your ships faster than light jump drive
consumes one unit of fuel for every
parsec of distance it takes you and your
ship holds only 15 units of fuel but the
space station is 23 parsecs away and
there's only empty space between there
and here there's one thing that can help
you though
Dark Matter fuel is stable in deep space
that means you can vent a cache of it
from your fuel chamber and then come
back to pick it up again later even
though your ship holds only 15 units of
fuel you've been granted use of all 45
units in your current location with some
strategic fuel caches along the way you
might be able to make it all 23 parsecs
so how can you reach the alien space
station
[Music]
it's possible to solve this riddle using
as few as two cash points and there are
also valid solutions that use more no
matter how you go about it though the
key is determining exactly where to cash
fuel along your route let's work
backwards from the alien space station
to reach 23 parsecs you'll have to leave
the 8 parsec mark with a full tank of
fuel the 8 parsec point is too far from
the start to use as a cash right away
you could jump there but wouldn't have
enough fuel to return to the start let
alone store any for later so that means
you'll need to find a cash somewhere
between the start and 8:00 but where
there's an interesting pattern that can
help at the start you have exactly 3
tanks worth of fuel at 8 parsecs you
need exactly one is there a point which
we can call point X where you could have
exactly two that would be useful because
then you could refuel there exactly
twice making full use of your storage
capacity without any waste wherever
point X is you'll jump forward from it
twice once to deposit some fuel at the
eight parsecs cash point and a second
time for good
so you'll jump the distance between X
and 8 parsecs three times in all you'd
have two tanks of fuel at point X and
need one left at the eight parsec cash
point so you can spend one tank or 15
units going back and forth since 15
units divided by three trips is five we
can place these two cash points five
parsecs apart any farther and you
wouldn't have enough fuel to reach the
alien space station so it looks like the
earliest we can place point X is at the
three parsec mark is it possible to
transport 30 units of fuel there let's
try you set out with a full tank of 15
units you jump three parsecs drop nine
units off at the cash point and then
jump the three units home arriving with
an empty tank repeating this process
gets you 18 units of fuel at the cash
point and one more jump put
you at the three parsec cache with 30
total units of fuel so far so good
next you jump to the eight parsec mark
drop off five units of fuel and jump
back to the three parsec mark you fill
up your tank and jump forward again
arriving with ten units of fuel in your
tank and now the end is in sight you
beam the five units of fuel in from deep
space to fill your tank to capacity and
type in the coordinates of your final
destination a 15 parsec jump leaves you
running on fumes but ready to dock with
the precursor Space Station time to put
this alien tech to work and make life
better for everyone in the galaxy
do you have what it takes to apprehend a
group of fugitives zipping around the
galaxy join an interstellar police squad
and help bring these criminals to
justice